you know the holidays are over when you
have to put away the Christmas
decorations it's been so long since I
had a Christmas tree at my place but
this year I decided to get festive as
I'm taking down all of the decorations I
am really regretting ever setting this
up and little did I know that the worst
part of this entire tear down would be
putting it in this Christmas tree bag
like the freaking website said it would
fit a 9ft tree and girl math things
didn't go as plan so I called in backup
Jenna helps me and the massage chair is
back in action after some severe
vacuuming because who thought a flocked
tree was a good idea flocked Garland
even worse there's glitter all over the
place glitter pine cones sure this
glitter is going to be here until next
year ho ho ho also my storage unit is
full I am really loving truck life
though and the 20123 holiday season has
officially come to a close do you think
I will be decorating next year hard to
say